all right welcome to a very special
edition of beginner breakdown
I'm Jonathan Tron's filling in for Mike
comer it's the the last beginner
breakdown of the year and as Mike has
taught us not only is Mike a superb and
excellent chess coach he's also a superb
an excellent life coach which the one
thing he's taught us if he's only taught
us one thing and he's taught us so many
things is and there's a spoiler alert
coming so if you want to go watch his
meaning of life revealed video before
you you understand what life is about
you may want to do that now he's taught
us there life is all about getting glory
so here I am at the end of the year
getting the very last beginner breakdown
credit and he's at home still out of
shape because he stopped working out
with me but by the time you see this
video that might be reversed maybe he's
working out with me again so alright I'm
filling in for Mike today we'll get a
little serious my I played a game my
last game that I played online was
against a feed a master normally we pick
on little kids like right up front here
we got a couple kids we could pick on
but I decided to go after a feed a
master he didn't play the best game but
once you see the opening you'll you'll
understand why I'm showing this on
beginner breakdown so it was an e4 e5
opening and after some normal moves I
decided to go in for the Italian game a
Mike comer specialty it was to be fair
to myself I didn't see the lecture that
I had given yesterday and realized how
awesome the Scotch is so I couldn't play
that I hadn't studied it yet so okay and
all right I think this is a really good
opening for beginners to play and the
two Knights defense is a really good way
for black to meet this now if you're too
high rated to be watching a beginner
breakdown you'll probably play the move
d3 here because that's what all the top
players do and it's probably the best
move but it wouldn't be beginner
breakdown
didn't play Knight to g5 okay so maybe
people haven't seen this I know we got
some some newcomers here so the threat
is to take on f7 and how does black peri
this threat what's the what can we do to
block this diagonal Aspen d5 excellent
and she already knows it okay excellent
so there's nothing better than taking so
that's what happened and a very strange
thing happened the day I played this
game I got to this position and there's
two moves that I know really well here
one is is taking on d5 which is not very
good and the other is the main line
Knight to a5 so I was feeling pretty
well prepared to face either one of
those but I got surprised I had this
position twice against some pretty high
rated opponents and I got two different
moves that I'd never seen so really
there's about four variations that you
want to know so we're going to go over
some of the lesser variations that don't
get to make an appearance on beginner
breakdown very often one of those moves
the first game I played was the move b5
a crazy-looking move this is the Elvis
Todd variation so we'll take a look at
that in just a moment and then there's
what my opponent played which is the
Fritz variation Knight to d4 all right
if we didn't explain the fried liver
this wouldn't be beginner breakdown so
we'll go over one game really quick it's
not the focus of our lecture but okay so
the fried liver as we've seen many times
in this class and alright so the point
is we've you know forced the King to
move to the center of the board and at
some point after we tack the knight
again black is going to have to figure
out how he's going to defend his Knight
one way is to retreat a knight but that
does block in the bishop and okay I move
like d4 is coming and that's going to be
a really strong move and the other way
is in a game and I wanted to show this
game it's an instructive game shear off
was playing with the white pieces in the
2000
14 chess olympiad and I think his move
here was excellent in this position
black is threatening to fork you on c2
he's going to attack the king and the
rook but sheer up here he allowed it and
even begged black to play it he played
the move a3 which if you put this on
your engine it's going to say this is a
slight inaccuracy but then if you go
through this game they're playing all
the forced moves and then suddenly it
says white is winning so I think sheriff
probably did this homework and this line
may well just be refuted so in that game
okay so he got to take and he gets to
win the rook but now this guy is
undefended so we're going to get a piece
back sheera took with his knight now
he's threatening some discovered checks
so the King gets out of the way and now
another strong move d4 so it'd be really
ill-advised for black to take this and
allow the bishop to come to this
diagonal the bishop would simply be way
too strong so in this position he
instead got his bishop out and so now
White has the option of taking but it
might not be in his best interest after
all his King is on the D file and there
is a black Queen on the D file so that's
not the file he really wants to open up
the tension really favors white since
black is never really threatening to
take on e4 so instead he just builds on
the pressure rook to e1 getting all of
his pieces into the game you'll notice
this is you know some black when he goes
and wins the material like this in the
corner that Knight often is going to end
up trapped and the most important
feature is obviously this King on e6 so
we'll go through okay it's hard to find
a move here for black what he tried in
the game was was b5 and alright there's
more to this lecture so we'll we'll go
through a few moves a nice tactic and
alright so here he can win some more
material you'll notice the Queen and
King are on the same diagonal so what
did white play here if we can get some
new hands so a lot of new people here
do you see it what is it excellent yeah
Bishop to g5 skewering the King whoop
skewering the king to the Queen alright
so he won some material here now the
only thing that could possibly happen
that would be bad is you know letting
him take this deep on but White has a
good way of rounding up the e5 pawn he
takes with check and then he gets to
pick up the pawn and again we're going
quickly through this game because
there's there's a lot more where we're
really going to focus on but uh okay so
now after misplacing the black King he
gets to pick up the C pawn and now this
Knight is trapped so he's not going to
escape at all uh ra v doesn't really do
much except for make the knight try to
find a better square but it's hard for
black to do anything he's just kind of
paralyzed here so now after this trade
White has a discovered check so the King
has to move and okay a very tricky move
now it might appear that this pawn is
attacked twice because it's attacked
twice but there is a trick White has a
little tactic so if we imagine the
bishop takes what would white play here
when I go to the back of the room for
this Queen d3 excellent Dany Machuca
everybody all right right so the check
on the King it's a double attack and
then wherever the King moved we'd be
able to win some material here and
similarly if the rook takes we would
trade first and then this check okay so
in this position he didn't take he
played g6 and now another little cute
tactical move he just hooked upon on g6
and black resigned so the point is now
if you take what is white playing why
did he give up his rook do you know the
answer yeah all right a good job
Jonathan Queen e6 double attack here so
he would pick up the rook and black it
had enough if you you know count the
material even in such a position though
there's nowhere I'd really want to put
my king okay it's a knight a bishop and
a rook but the quality of this the
central Queen and the strength of this
pawn means game over for black so that
was just an excellent demonstration of
how to dismantle the black King when you
play the fried liver and all right this
game was played in an Olympiad so it's
tough when you have to play share of in
a team event but it doesn't help your
team if you're playing the fried liver
so not the best choice but okay there
are other moves here on the main line
which will show very briefly is Knight
to a5 so there's a whole way we'll
typically do is first he's going to give
this check and after black blocks white
will be up upon and now there's lots of
bishop retreats that are moves Bishop e2
is the most common Bishop f1 is a common
move Bishop d3 is a move that I like to
play and especially if you play Bill
Thompson
you should play Bishop to d3 because he
always plays the same way normally in
these lines when the bishop is somewhere
else
black kicks this night away and then the
bishop gets but in this line the knight
gets to go to e4 and whenever I play
bill he goes like this and I'm up upon
and my bishops awesome so you play bill
a lot so this is the secret and I told
him about this and he still does this so
now Ben Simon knows how to beat Bill
Thompson you learned something mmm all
right but uh okay after this
we'll look at the most common move just
give you sort of an idea of what happens
when they play the main main line now
each six makes sense kicking the night
back and you're going to gain more time
on the night kicking them away again so
then I has to make a you know risky
adventure into e5 but why it's always
going to have the saving move d4 to help
save his night an example of the
initiative that black might get for his
pawn is in a following continuation so
if you know the on passant rule you'll
understand what just happened
and okay so we'll just go up typical
development these moves preventing white
from castling because if you castle the
H pawn would be unprotected and all
right we'll just go a few moves so you
can get an idea this is sort of the
domain line h3 so that you can castle
and you get to such a position and white
and black has a certain compensation
here for the pawn as indicated by these
very scary arrows so we'll draw lots of
scary arrows so you get scared and this
is sort of a normal position that's been
reached several times things you know
similar to this and alright it's alright
for both sides it's a decent way to play
but now we're going to look at the
unusual stuff so in this position
there's two unusual moves but I face
them both on the same day one of those
the first one that I faced was Bishop to
b5 and I didn't play the best move here
the main move might surprise you what
would you guys play here as white that's
the main move yeah Bishop f1 is the main
move I played Bishop takes pawn and I
just say alright what is I didn't know
what the trick was so I said alright
show it to me um but now this allows a
double attack here for black and I
played the trickiest move most the main
line is just to take this so we'll look
at that in a second but that's kind of
scary for white I played the trickiest
move which is Bishop to e2 and he fell
for the trick immediately because he
took this Jeep on
and then what winning move did I play so
it looks it's looking good for black
until you see my next move
do you see it
Bishop f3 right and then he took this
and I took here with check and I took
another piece and then I won so ok so he
didn't have to take on g2 the main line
in this position is taking though it can
be kind of scary for white so black it's
to make this threat this night isn't
really very useful on g5 so if you
retreat it you know you get some
position like this black is going to put
a rook on the D file and prepare to
break through with E 4 so in this one
game between two Greek players with
names impossible for me to pronounce so
I won't even try we'll see what happened
in this game black just got a huge
initiative based off the fact that ie 4
is such a powerful move okay we'll just
sure if you Castle right here yeah and
this is a yeah the computer wanted to
see this as well so this is a very good
continuation
yeah the King is decent here there's no
attack by white and yeah move like efore
is coming so if we made a bad move well
not not terrible but just to illustrate
the point white wouldn't be able to open
up this this file even if after some
trades because there's this you know
these threats on the D file so yeah so
castling queenside is a very good move
in this disposition in a in this one
game though he went to the other side
and black got to move efore in so he
even sacrificed a little bit of material
here when he took the night and after
this exchange he's in some pretty bad
shape he decided to move his knight
which is the losing move so all right
now we're noticing there's going to be
some tactics here because the Queen
wants to take on g2 but
his own night is in the way also if you
just move the night somewhere okay then
your queen is falling so black has to
find a really nice move but there is a
winning continuation here so we'll see
if the audience can find it it's tricky
there's a lot going on this is a
potential threat
you know White has a threat there's a
rook here that wants to take something
all right excellent you want to take
this guy excellent that was played and
when white took back how did you want to
follow up right yeah rook takes Knight
and whites and some some bad shape here
in the game he tried putting his King
back but now black can move this Knight
anywhere in threatened checkmate so he
found a good square he attacked a queen
so white can you know give up his Queen
and avoid checkmate which is what the
computer wants to do but he tried to
play Queen f3 which loses instantly so
who can see there's a checkmate now do
you see it
yeah not quite not quite all right it
was a good try though right right a very
good try
give it yeah ninety-two so you're
forcing the King to the H file now
notice how nice your night is the King
doesn't get to escape now all you got to
do is put a piece on the H file so he
brought his rook over and white resigned
if you block now your queen is pinned so
this would be checkmate
all right so an excellent example of the
the powerful initiative black can get
for the pawn okay and that's why in this
variation after b5 most people will play
Bishop to f1 the point being that now
after the the knight moves we're going
to win this pawn but we're going to win
it a little bit later and since somebody
had played this against me
I studied this particular pawn structure
that you're going to get after this very
tricky move we're now both Knights are
hanging I'm attacking his knight he's
attacking my knight so you can play a
move like Knight to e4 that's a decent
alternative but the move I studied after
this game that was interesting to me was
taking the knight getting this very
unusual pawn structure but if you play
this opening it's actually quite common
so there's a lot of games with this and
since I just studied this weird pawn
structure you'll see it again when I
played the f-m so he took okay so black
will normally take and now you get this
check in and there's no really good way
to block so they're going to put their
King on d8 which is advantageous for
white black is threatening the jeep on
but I move my Queen f3 is very nice and
after some moves like this you get a
very pleasant position with the white
pieces to show you one you know kind of
complicated follow up we can imagine
this is something that's happened
several times the move Knight to e3 so
okay so there are some some threats here
this rook is trying to take your bishop
it's a it's very complicated
so the queen has to go somewhere where
it's protecting the Jeep on obviously
this checkmate was is to be avoided so
and there's this a complicated position
that occurs and this has been played
more than once so okay and white should
be slightly better here you know he's
going to play a move like like d4 he's
going to get this he's gonna protect his
Bishop and weights a little bit better
but it's still complicated and blacks up
to a lot of mischief so this is
something that that's interesting to
play so if you look at these lines
you're going to see this kind of sort of
stuff mmm okay so instead let's get back
to the real game that we're here to see
okay Knight to d4 the Fritz variation
and now we'll go a little bit slower and
we'll focus on this game now I
immediately played castles and then I
immediately regretted it I should
definitely play the move c3 in this
position to immediately questioned this
Knight and here he can play the move b5
and transpose to the other variation I
could again play you know Bishop to f1
and we could get this same position
where now after he's taking I'm taking
here and we get this same position as
before so that was possible but okay but
because I Castle die lost the ability to
go for that line so he took my pawn on
d5 I'm revealing an attack on my knight
but obviously if his Queen moves then
his knight on d5 will be unprotected
so having studied that pawn structure
from before I played the move c3
intending if he took my Knight as he did
that I would take back and okay I also
considered you know Bishop takes d5 not
compromising my pawn structure and
perhaps it's a better move but having
just seen the pawn structure that I was
I was studying I said okay I'm gonna go
in for this and alright and so the
position should be equal ish and now
black is going to get a scary-looking
attack but it's not really that scary
but here he made a big threat so okay
the threat of checkmate is strong so how
did I stop
from getting checkmated
or did I just get checkmated and good
right good lecture I just got I just got
checkmated do you have an idea excellent
yeah I played right you mentioned two
moves Queen f3 or g3 I didn't want a
week in my kingside structure because I
realize you know there's a there's a
bishop and a knight they might want to
come occupy some of these squares this
Bishop also would be good if it made its
way to f3 so I decided I didn't want a
week in my pawn structure so after we go
back a little bit I play Queen to f3 and
then he played the move Bishop to d6
which at the time I thought was the
losing move I thought I was winning
already because after I take here
there's going to be some stuff on the
e-file but uh we'll look at that because
that's what was that's what happened in
the game but here after I take if you're
really cutting there's a way for black
to equalize here he should you know
start to think that he's going to be a
lot worse because bad stuff is going to
happen on the e-file but this one is
actually a really tough one so we're
looking to the people in the back here
to try to find this answer what should
black play in this situation have you
got it in the front Bishop h3 yes that's
yeah so it's an interesting move that I
didn't even consider you know I assume I
can take your bishop or I assume I can
play d4 let me take your bishop
what were you going to play here
how do you want to take it because
everything could take it so okay so my
idea was I'm going to try to trade
Queens and not get checkmated i'ma try
yeah so even if if you play this check I
can just move my king okay I mean you
can trade stuff and take my rook but
okay looks looks pretty good for me so
that's actually not the answer though
that was an interesting one those a good
a good try so the main move that he
could have played is Knight to h3 so the
knight is protected by the bishop so my
queen can't just grab it so I'd have to
move my king unless I want to lose my
queen but when my king moves now black
can take this pawn with a big threat and
what would have nothing better than to
trade off the Queens and we'd go into
this equalist position now the knight
can retreat and I didn't get checkmated
but now do the liquidation black should
be able to get back into this game
pretty easily the knight will be able to
escape and we'll just get our pieces out
and so this was blacks best try and he's
certainly not losing if he finds that
continuation but in the game
he took the pawn so what did I play here
yeah
so if I play rookie one immediately he
might be able to get out of some of the
trouble by castling now the the queen is
protecting the bishop though this is
still pretty good for me well there's
something even stronger check with the
bishop here here what does this check
get you you're gonna so if I play here
you're taking it that's what you're
thinking okay so that's actually
interesting move yeah the point is he's
trying to wind a lot of stuff here I
wonder if I can be really brave I don't
know but I'm going to try to be really
brave so if you like take this I'm going
to try to checkmate you I don't know I'm
gonna try mmm right yeah okay so here it
might be different though with the
inclusion of this Bishop because now you
know this check would win the Queen so
it is a little bit different okay and I
don't have to play c6 I could you know
like move my king and be a little bit
worse that way or be a little gutsy and
get my King into the center of the game
but okay but yeah this is actually an
interesting move so and I didn't
consider that during the game so that's
that's an excellent try and it probably
is pretty good for white because blacks
position is really bad now but I played
the move d4 exploiting the fact that the
bishop is stuck guarding the knight now
that I've Unleashed another attacker so
if you you know you take my pawn then I
take your your knight so I thought he
was going to play the best move which is
Bishop to d6 but he surprised me he
didn't play that move and then I'd be
better because I would get this check in
Miss places King and I'd play a move
like Knight to c3 threatening to you
know eliminate this bishop which is one
key defenders of f4 so okay so then I
would just be better that's what I
assumed was was going to happen but he
surprised me
he played Bishop to g4 which is a very
bad move but this was a three minute
game and so it's scary when there's this
many pieces by your King so I got to be
pretty careful here
whenever the bishop moves you'll notice
that the B pond is no longer defended so
I have a nice safe move I can safely
take the B pond that's what I did I'm
attacking the rook and my queen is still
useful on this diagonal because in some
lines when I need to protect the Jeep on
she is still there for me but you know
it's it's scary that's a lot of pieces
by my king and now he did something
strange again he could just castle but
then he loses his bishop so he decided
to offer me a rook or maybe two rooks so
the real theme of today is going to be
some double rook sacrifices which are
you know incredibly rewarding when it
works here I have the opportunity to
take his rook with Czech so I did it and
he played an inaccuracy he put his King
on e7 which is a mistake because some
lines I'll be able to give this check
actually if he goes to d7 and I decide
to accept this sacrifice I'm losing
because now black has a winning attack
look in black play here
and this is the point of a double rook
sacrifice it's usually a queen that's
you know taking both of the rooks and
what's interesting about it is the time
that you gained can be used to checkmate
your opponent all right so it's in this
position you are asking about Knight to
h3
and okay so one thing I can do is I can
move my king but I'm wondering if I can
just take your knight the point is if
you take here thinking your checkmating
me you're going to be kind of sad so
okay so that's that's interesting now if
I can do this without messing it up
again okay so we didn't find the winning
move here
does anyone have it maybe somebody in
the back have you got it
Knight e to check okay so if I take it
I'm not getting checkmated so I'm happy
to trade some pieces and okay you can
trade but uh all right but I think Paul
sees it what's it Bishop f3 so the
immediate threat is checkmate notice
that I can't play g3 because 9 h3
excellent so yeah the knight attacks it
the bishop covers the light squares the
knight isn't touching and we got a
checkmate there is a way to avoid
getting mated immediately though you can
give away your queen the point being
not that you're escaping one more move
we actually do create an escape square
for your King so after this King goes
somewhere and you have to play this move
well you're still alive
it's it's a pleasure to be black here
but you didn't get checkmated
immediately okay but in the game he
played King to e7 now if I wanted to I
could take this but it was a 3-minute
game and so I didn't have a whole lot of
time to calculate but uh
okay if I take this now it's a little
bit different if he plays Bishop f3
again now I have rook to e1 with check
and there's not a good way to block and
the obvious king running away move leads
to a checkmate
so for example if you try to check me
and block still threatening mate what
move will white play person just walking
in the room right but White's in check
double check all right so we got double
check suggested all right but white can
just take this because you're in check
and okay your queen is hanging so okay
right it was a tough one okay but in the
game since it was a quick game I decided
to play practically I just moved my my
queen back to e for checking the king
and alright so he still has some dreams
of checkmating me and I didn't really
necessarily play the best move but I
played the most practical I just traded
pieces because now there's less pieces
or surrounding my King and after he took
back Knight c3 forced resignation
so I'm threatening just to play Knight
to c5 and win this bishop and I have a
lot more pieces and I didn't get
checkmated and his King is on f6 so he
had had enough so that was you know an
example of somebody that you know it's
probably much higher rated than you but
even they play you know some pretty
terrible games sometimes
this was me versus some FM on the
internet so alright alright so this that
game that we just showed really inspired
me for the rest of this lecture we're
going to look at two more games here
real quick with some double rook
sacrifices that actually worked so I had
the potential to take two of my
opponent's rooks
but I didn't go for it but here we're
going to see a game between T'Pol off
and Barea where it worked and it was
actually brilliant and when I first
started playing chess I had a coach he
was just some dad at my school so he
didn't really know much about chess
but he showed me a double rook sacrifice
and I thought it was brilliant and I
looked it up before this lecture and
every move was a blunder so I couldn't
show that game I had to find some games
where it actually worked
all right and it works here the French
defense and we enter a line that you
might not suspect is going to end in 19
moves the burn variation like its cousin
the the Rubenstein is known to be really
solid and it's probably not the way I'd
recommend a beginner to play but for
grandmasters when a draw is good with
black you know it's a perfectly fine
opening and so we got disposition and
now one time on chess calm after the
normal move which was not played an
opponent who got banned for cheating
they played the move Bishop to e7 here
and so then I decided since that's what
the computer that guy liked was just
using computer I played that in a
tournament game and it wasn't very good
because the bishop is better here on f6
so I learned my lesson but in this game
instead of the normal continuation white
played the move c3 and he had an idea
that didn't really work okay so now
black is ready if white ever wants to
trade he can take back with a knight and
now when black gets the movie five in
you sort of equalized now this bishop is
going to have a good time getting out
and okay what is white going to do after
such a move now it's not often when you
see the strongest in the world playing
that they don't develop their pieces and
castle so White's plan was to push here
on the Kings side and in such a position
black gets castled and white is going to
have a hard time castling why don't
these people play this against me well I
play grandmasters they develop all their
pieces and castle but when they play
each other they make a lot of mistakes
and they don't do anything so very
interesting mmm okay now white decides
to block the D file now he might Castle
but black stopped him with a very
interesting move Queen to d5 the Queen
is on the same diagonal as a rook
and if you castle you're a pawn is
hanging so a clever way of disrupting
white from castling now if you trade
here which was not played you may think
okay I have a way to protect my rook and
attack your Queen but now what would
black play maybe somebody in the front
can find it hmm double check yeah
anybody yeah awesome yeah rook e8 and
you're going to lose this piece here so
excellent move it'll never end with that
okay so a nice disruptive move and so
white still has the attention of
castling so a3 was played and now this
is black's last chance to do something
really cool before white gets castled so
this is what typically happens so if
you're looking for a sacrifice now is
the time so maybe somebody who's higher
rated in the audience can find what
black played here Knight takes f4 was
played the point being if you take the
knight we'll get this check in and after
a move like f4 you're still having
problems on this diagonal you can you
can try for one more trick and maybe I
won't see that you can pin my Queen
but if black just moves over well you're
going to run into some trouble your King
doesn't belong on f1 and you have some
problems here so instead that wasn't
played he has another possibility white
does of taking this bishop which was
played and now taking on h7 which was
played so the King has to move and now
white made a mistake but it was hard to
imagine that it's a mistake
he put his Queen on e4 and if white
trades Queens then he's going to be
happy he's not going to get mated but if
you remember the theme of this lecture
you
might find the next move so here is the
really truly brilliant move and the
computer doesn't see it until you tell
it it says black is you know probably
winning and then you tell it this move
and it's like yeah blacks really winning
so what amazing and stunning moved to
black play in a double rook sacrifice
lecture rook e8 alright this guy here
he's okay okay so that was played
attacking the Queen so the Queen has to
take it he took it yeah oh sorry yeah
you blundered your queen all right now
he offered another rook so what's going
on you know why did black give away all
of his rooks you better have checkmate
and it's actually mate in ten here so
sometimes I have students that they'll
play like mate and 11 or 12 here they
won't play accurately and that drives me
crazy
when's they have time when you have time
to sit and calculate and this was a long
game so you probably calculate it and he
played it correctly anyone for checkmate
you should do that and try to practice
your calculation you know this is about
to be a masterpiece you've sacrificed
both of your rooks and now you're going
to checkmate white so at the end it
better be a really pretty picture it
should be nice enough that they could
display it at the world chess Hall of
Fame this is your canvas and this is
your art so you need to checkmate them
as fast as possible and black found a
way to do that okay so it's obvious the
King is is getting a little exercise
here so after a few more moves all right
white figured it out yeah it's over so
he he resigned in this position so this
is a case we're giving up both rooks who
actually was not only correct it was
very exciting and he polished off the
game with excellent technique so
all right so one more game that we got
for you with a double rook sacrifice
this is a game between Alexander
Alekhine and Gregory Levin fish so a
classic game this also had a really
exciting finish
so we'll get we'll just get serious here
we'll put the opening on the board and
f4 was played the most aggressive way
for white to fight against this he's
going to play e5 as soon as possible and
here it really worked so after a six you
you might just casually play a four to
stop b5 but here the move e5 is really
strong and it was played okay so in this
position he gets the movie six in which
is good in chess and bughouse
so either way white White's doing pretty
good if we we don't mention the f2
square mm okay and now a strange
decision I feel like the next move for
white is fairly obvious and the computer
agrees but I'm not a world champion and
this guy is so what do I know
h3 just seems like a natural move to me
and after the capture you know taking
and playing g4 seems like a very strong
continuation but instead the unusual
Bishop to f4 not as good but it works
out well in the game and after the trade
again I would definitely take with a
queen he took with a pond forcing the
knight back and all right so he could
take here that's certainly a possibility
and the other interesting option is to
make sure you keep upon on e6 which is
what white decided to do so even if you
you take here we're going to be able to
keep this pawn on e6 for awhile it's
very frustrating for the black king with
the pond there because even if you play
a move like b5 now white is going to be
able to sacrifice because you're gonna
have some problems here you're gonna end
up giving up a piece and you lost a lot
of puns so okay mm mm so that's an
annoying an annoying pawn just like
we're using an annoying software to make
this film and uh okay let's see let's
see
so I took and now black could trade
Queens if he wants but this rook is
going to be really good on the D file
and you know it's hard to be the black
King here so instead he decided to play
Queen to b6 see if I can do this without
messing up the computer threatening to
break one of my rules never play Queen
takes b2 especially not here when you're
underdeveloped this is exactly the kind
of situation where it might backfire and
we're going to see that so instead of
guarding the b2 pond
he lets black take it and black obliged
and now we get to the studying part of
the lecture white played a fantastic
move here black might be feeling pretty
happy he's attacking lots of your pieces
and the knight he could take with check
so you could take rooks and take Knights
so white has to play a really nice move
here right so we can't even like you
know just connect our rooks because the
night is falling Queen d2 yeah this is
interesting so yeah so you're trying to
get a sacrifice this way
where you going to Bishop to c7 you're
going to try to checkmate me yeah yeah
yes this is also interesting so somehow
I'll try not to get checkmated I mean
I'm gonna try you can try checkmate me
I'll try not to get checkmated mm um he
actually played a you know a slightly
more outstanding move let's see if it
will let me Knight to b5 okay so yeah
he's he's coming in here to c7 and black
decided to help himself to a pair of
rooks so he's feeling pretty good about
that but now Knight to c7 is uh going to
end the game here so the King had to
move after this check he decided to
block and but once we take alright the
the threat of
six is a game ender so black gave it up
here and the reason it's unlikely that
you'll actually get a double rook
sacrifice it doesn't come up that often
but the reason I like to bring it up is
because it emphasizes the importance of
time in chess so sometimes they'll be
taking some of your material but if you
have a strong attack or you're making
some stronger threats it's worth taking
the time to see if you can give up some
of your stuff let them take it and then
go checkmate them so I hope you enjoyed
that this is the last beginner breakdown
of the year we'll see you again next
year thanks for coming